a car they call lobsters bugs out there
yeah they do while they're in the bed of
resident shut the [ __ ] up about animals
I'm just talking about Australia and he
was so happy to go why do we call them
bugs cuz yeah I'm tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing me and I were doing set it the
Phoenix stand up live in Phoenix I leave
I don't he gets there before me in the
room there's comics going on before us
then we're doing firing kid life and I
go Brian goes early and he's there with
the comics than green room and I'm I
just sneak in and Brian's telling a
fight story to these four comics and
they're looking up just throwing and
throwing my tea and he's my hand he's
going the other than that one
[ __ ] came out dead serious how
are you what are you doing oh what's up
like I got caught I handed like hot wet
fellows the line you guys are buying
this [ __ ] and they're like you
talking about master Callen like oh hell
yes when I'm not here this out this is
even worse
it's almost like fighting I actually
believe if you if you're if you're in a
bar on a guy who makes you mad enough to
fight and try to really hurt him and
knock him out in a way the times I've
been in fights I I wanted to kill the
guy I wasn't just going to punch him I
was I had deep hatred and in that moment
I was trying to kill him
can you relate to this chin or mother am
I the only normal person in the room I'm
telling you be
I've never wonder you're just a
different sort but it was not my girl
with so Joe and I have a baby together
if I came home tonight she won't listen
I just got done [ __ ] seven dudes
there's nothing in my body that would go
through my mind to kill her that does
not exist in me any fight I've ever been
I've been I'm Way more fight than you
never once you've been you've also been
in what I'm saying is you've also been
I'm a street fighter very place I've
been more Street I don't think you bet
him more than I've been I don't I've
been I've been drunk rich wait hold on
huh don't tell me that cuz you don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
you've been as many faces you've been in
in sorry I know you dude you don't fight
I know you don't tell me how much wait
why do you don't know me you don't know
how I grew up as in as in getting in
fights in a bar you oh you almost saw me
get into fights since you've known me
what are you talking about don't say
that you don't have the kind of temper I
do don't don't act like you've been in
more fight you're acting like all I grew
up rich first of all I put on the stuff
is that fights with then you Brian
what how many fights have been I
couldn't even count you I know you I
know how people you grew up in it you I
know your personality
you weren't fight street fighting all
the time I was street fighting a street
fight with my brother the neighborhood
we grew
sure your boiler though it's the way we
grew up be yeah I I fought plenty in
high school and in college you're some
bad I'm not your some bad like saying
fight or anything I'm a badass why are
you doing that being insulting I'm not
being salty I just called you by my
house no you're not you're being
condescending what you sow you're going
you rub rich and haven't fought don't
say that you don't know me so fat
because I have a bad temper you see how
I'm not upset exactly do I know what to
Turner I don't get the phone making up
I'm making up stories you make up a lot
of stories I make up a lot of stories I
make up so I'm a liar yeah I'm a lie
shoot me a story I was invited I was
like hopefully we get along and have a
[ __ ] throw because I have massive
respect you know Brian's a crazy
[ __ ] I tell story you know that
whole school down there was a fun
III wanted to tell the story about Brian
because he always went smooth so one
time I used to work at all the
underground hip-hop clubs in New York so
my friend was doing a party and it was
all [ __ ] deep Brooklyn heads [ __ ]
like homeboys and [ __ ] like the real
deal this hip-hop club and I take Brian
another dude from the school and Tony
and we go over there and Brian is in the
middle of the [ __ ] dance floor doing
the funky [ __ ] white boy nerd dance
and all these [ __ ] and the floor just
opens up and he's [ __ ] black [ __ ]
hip-hop crazy [ __ ] homeboys are like
yo look at this [ __ ] white boy
like it's bugging and he don't give a
[ __ ] he's seriously like a [ __ ] piss
ative to roll with so then I might go I
gotta go but listen man I know what
y'all [ __ ] do don't start no
[ __ ] please it's my friends club so I
get home go to sleep wake up the next
day I get a [ __ ] phone call yo like
he didn't know that they were with me so
I killed it was these three [ __ ]
karate experts in the club last night
and they beat up all my [ __ ] bouncers
dude it was [ __ ] crazy like and one
bouncer walked up and started some [ __ ]
with Tony was trying to talk to a girl
what
and and then like you know this guy is
all on the juice rips off his shirt like
[ __ ] Tony throws a kick [ __ ]
dislocates the guy's [ __ ] kneecap and
then the first moves on me the melee
just ensued any it was just constant
these [ __ ] huge bouncers comin at him
and Brian Sipe I [ __ ] bryophyte Brian
is uh you know nothing he's a comedian
but he could throw down and then he
Brian just told me this because I didn't
hear the other part he goes yeah then
all of a sudden I'm [ __ ] whacking
these dudes and us we're fighting these
guys and then this [ __ ] gigantic
[ __ ] like I was just like a
little [ __ ] baby in his arms lifts me
up and carries me out the [ __ ] door
and throws me across this car and I look
and I turn around and I'm ready to go
and then Brian says and I look and it's
this [ __ ] crazy white dude with a
[ __ ] scar from one end of his face
down his throat and he points that
behind it goes don't even think about it
and like Brian was like yo well my
friend called me up the next days like
these [ __ ] and I call him up
and I'm my Brian the [ __ ] did you do man
I told you guys to [ __ ] keep Chuy's
like y'all these bouncers were a so
don't fear Joe Rogan I don't feel Joe
Rogan I fear that [ __ ] guy and I'll
fear you it's weird crushes cuz you
don't think that Joe and job and I could
[ __ ] rip you to shreds ro do me a
favor if you decide to step into that
ring and I'm being dead serious let's go
I'm being dead seal of z' make sure no
Bluffs make sure gloves no gloves I'm
we're talking about a street fight make
sure well you set a ring right make sure
you if you step over the line
we got gloves all right well if somebody
if we happen to cross a ring in
straightest is the Alzheimer's kickin
but you just know this know this if you
guys if you want a street fight with me
yeah pack a [ __ ] lunch bro I'd say
package you're gonna be there a while
we're gonna fight all day is that what
you're saying I try the air that's gonna
Wow okay good you're gonna kill all the
bacteria
you can't yeah you can okay I'm gonna I
could you think do you really think in a
crazy street fight yeah you and I yeah
that it's gonna take that long from
sunup to sundown I'm gonna have you ever
done anything wild worth low blow yeah
all first Martha shovel Slugger Santino
Slugger Santino sluggers no no you know
I've heard the stories of sluggers
things before we get into how you're
gonna train I want you to know something
and I mean this so seriously and so
sincerely I'm gonna say thank you I took
a nap a Rip Van Winkle map for five
years I woke up with my hair way too
long my nails way too long and my
[ __ ] beard way hydrated and Dee high
five yours laughs hey that's the main
question behind okay let me up after my
Rip Van Winkle nap you've been training
I mean training yeah I mean so can your
shirt in your shorts and your undies
every single [ __ ] bag right you still
being them whoopee
you don't last one round bro you
understand me I'm talking to my nails
head I can't make a fist I be he did do
Jiu Jitsu for pleasure Chris did I know
he did for six years and I want to say
this [ __ ] you what [ __ ] your [ __ ] oh
wow Jiu Jitsu
okay if you know step to me when you're
ready phone is right in the mouth but
bring it to these I'll slip that punch
that's all I do not lay out Freddie
Roach today all I showed him your video
only went tell him to stop did you say
trained my boy cuz he's a fight
enthusiast I did I said can you train
Brian Cowen or Todd Feldman and he goes
for you you know I'll do what I'll have
him killed
whoa go Freddy no I think we're off on
this no nice there's no not kill both of
them if they ever attempt a box again
what no that's no I'm looking for it
already has Jamie move late now I showed
him the video
and he the Freddy literally went like
this no no no Freddy please don't know I
I split it but check out top Feldman's
jabbing it no I slipped left right and
I'm very I'm always out of reach I'm not
being I'm not trying to be a dick I'm
always out of reach
I showed him Freddy said
imogen right now and I will knock both
them out to the body I'll fight him and
I put on 16-inch clouds and I'll move
around with you bring seen inch not
familiar 16-inch mean 16 loves or 16
inch and I will that's a porno all I
would say is this and you're a big
strong guy do me a favor your hands are
up no problem watch your midsection okay
cool cool cool man I don't like I'll
tell you what bothers me that you laugh
a little bit because today what the boys
at bars they're there and they're
grinding early yeah that was there yeah
I was a super early you should go down
okay to my boy Mario Lopez sure now
watch P's and Q's ready chomping at the
bit to get a hold of you chomping at the
bit I hear he actually I hate see Slater
Hawks waiting for you
AC Slater yeah gonna beat you up like
you're screech is that right they'll
[ __ ] you up like your screen how tall is
he what tall don't worry about that my
dad's in there bro how's he gonna get he
lives in there bro how's it gonna get
past my Jack let's find out
I got a Viper quick jab yep let's find
out I got a why don't you keep your
stupid head on I double and triple up my
jab that's fine man when you see my back
ripple and I pull myself up like a champ
like a champ through 30 times fast while
talking to you why wouldn't I give that
to you as it's a gets a gift it's a gift